again that's people thinking that a
quake is a spontaneous bad thing and
they're all fantastic smoothing it's
fantastic smooth
[Music]
this is StarTalk Cosmic queries Edition
this one is titled
Stark weeks I've got as a co-host here
Matt Kirsch and Matt welcome back to
start talk thank you so much for having
me it's nice to be back yeah so you
solicited questions about like stars and
star Quakes from I'm very excited about
this topic and so are the listeners
there's been a lot of a lot of your
patreon patrons have responded to this
one and we're gonna try and get through
as many of these as possible but uh I
can't promise all of them I will try I
don't know a damn thing about star
Quakes so yeah I know I'm excited I mean
I live in California where earthquakes
are a problem so I know how to deal with
those but I don't if you're involved in
a stock Quake do you it's getting under
a table still enough or how do we we're
gonna find out for sure so I guessed
with the expertise we need is Connie
Arts I think I pronounced that right
Connie welcome to start talk
hi glad to be here excellent now you
you're you're in from Belgium and the
Netherlands you have a dual appointment
one as the professor of astrophysics at
let me get this straight in
luvin Belgium and it's KU that's uh
Catholic University is like Catholic
University is that correct yeah can you
live and just don't worry about it
okay okay
there's a small college town in Belgium
excellent and in the Netherlands you're
a professor of Astro seismology at Route
University uh in the Netherlands and so
the fact that that's even a title to
hold Astro seismology uh it says How Far
We've Come uh in just the the the
um the specification within the broader
field of astrophysics and I think this
is this is just delightful and your
expertise is Stellar astrophysics
Stellar structure and evolution these
are two favorites of mine uh
professionally but I never really
thought about seismology in anything
other than Earth and so uh what first
tell us what is Astro seismology
well it's the study of the seismology of
stars now as you say and perhaps you do
better than that okay
so we all know earthquakes that the
Earth has a whole uh crust you know uh
it's not pleasant to have earthquakes
but it's fantastic to have stock Quakes
now stars are hot gaseous fears and they
also move up and down and we can use
these star Quakes to learn what's inside
the star it's the only way to know
how to look inside a star and that's
just like like seismologists of the
earth you know they they are the only
happy people uh when the art uh the
Earth is quaking let's say why because
the earthquakes create waves they travel
into this the the planets they bounce
back at the iron core and seismographs
detect it and then we can do all sorts
of fun physics and chemistry of our
planet and we do the same but then for
stars okay Matt I think Connie just said
that while cities are burning and
everyone is dying
geologists are delighted that they have
Earth absolutely yeah I'm hiding under a
table well my pets are going crazy and
uh and seismologists like the data what
beautiful data we're getting right now
yeah yeah so but I'm confused though
because when I think of an earthquake a
very simple
uh understanding of it that you have a
rigid crust that is under pressure and
under tension and then it's
spontaneously gives way
and then you get an Abrupt shift and
that's an earthquake but when I think of
stars they're fluids they're gaseous
fluids so what could possibly be quaking
if you don't have anything solid to
build up the tension that then gets
released yeah so that's a bit different
because the the star Quakes are
happening all the time because it's it's
a gas and so you have motions right up
and down motions but also more complex
uh motions and if you if you if you you
know press a gas and then release it it
creates sound waves that's a bit like
music in a theater Hall so for me stars
are three-dimensional Musical
and so uh the nice thing is that stock
Quakes are always there luckily for us
humans the earthquakes dry out quickly
right and they're rare relative I mean
they're rare in the sense of the ones
that do serious damage are rare but as I
understand it there are actually
earthquakes of even very small magnitude
almost all the time I think that's
correct is that right that's correct
because anybody in nature vibrates yeah
and so yeah stars do that all the time
and they do it permanently which for us
astrophysicist is great because we can
measure the up and down motion why
because it gives changes in the in the
temperature of the star and so the the
brightness of the star changes as a
function of time and then we have our
seismographs that measure these changes
as a function of time and your
seismographs are also I I you you
implied there that they're sensitive to
those
boundaries where temperature changes
right that's because your sound would
get reflected or your pressure wave
which we're calling sound would would
get reflected or bent in a different way
and you use that to model the in total
interior structure of the star is that
correct yeah that's correct but yeah
like
um we cannot hear these sound waves with
our ears so we see the brightness
variations because the sound is only
propagating there where there is gas and
between us and the star you know there's
nothing it's empty right so we got
literally here the the frequencies of
the waves but we see the up and down
motion and so that is actually connected
the frequency of these sound waves
created by these up and down motions is
connected to the physics and also the
chemical composition of the star in its
interior so we can't literally dive into
the Stellar Concert Hall that we can
measure the frequencies from a distance
let's say but if you could you would
hear all of these yeah yeah yeah that's
that's fantastic sometimes I give
lectures for musical artists and then
they are all totally fascinated
about these sounds like you know let me
test this on Matt so Matt NASA is going
to plan a mission to send astronauts to
the Sun to listen to these sounds but
it's dangerous obviously so they're
gonna go at night
you need your earplugs as well I you
know I go to loud concerts sometimes I
don't take any chances now I'm getting
older my hearing's going that by the way
I know I know we haven't got into the
questions yet uh but that actually is
one of our questions from Lucas uh from
listen to Lucas was actually about
whether you can make that the heartbeat
of stars into music
yes yeah so you're saying yes that you
can absolutely oh my goodness so have
people done so you so you have a
portfolio of frequencies going on at
different times in different locations
and so you get a clever musician to sort
of take all of that base material and
figure out a way to listen to it that
would be interesting yeah yeah so we we
actually just uh
shift I mean each star has its own
Symphony right depending on how big it
is how how much mass it has how old it
is it has its own Symphony but then we
shift that Global Symphony into the
audible range of humans that's that's
called summification it's a whole field
by itself and actually it allows blind
people to be astronomers I find that uh
I'm a very uh for me inclusion is very
important so in this way we can reach
people who can't see but they can hear
the stars but we have to help them a
little bit by shifting to the audible
range we have finally achieved the goals
of the ancients by celebrating the music
of the speaker yes yeah exactly
that's true yeah okay so that so that
question already got asked Matt so that
was who asked that that was that was
Lucas from New West who asked that
question where is what is New West what
is that I I don't know it just says New
West I'm not sure exactly but Lucas also
proceeds it by saying I have a geek kind
of question which I don't think you need
to proceed any questions to uh
safe space here everybody
you don't have to preface it but New
West I mean I live in New York and yeah
you know there's formerly New Amsterdam
just south of New England I've never
heard of New West I don't know what that
is maybe that's California after it
breaks away from the Senator's fault
just floating off just floating off into
the Pacific
so why don't we get some more questions
here this is great now that we have some
foundation for what yeah we've got some
awesome ones some of them have already
something we've already kind of answered
and I'm sure that'll happen as we go
along but I'll try and get as many ones
in so James Smith from Indianapolis says
what is the largest recorded Quake not
found here on Earth and also do all
planets have plates that shift like
Earth a couple of people have asked that
question as well whether so let's start
there first you know we know Earth is
geologically active because it's like
volcanoes and plate tectonics so uh
where else in the solar system might do
that before we get back to the Sun
oh well you know all planets will have
Greeks I mean any any body in nature
Crepes I I was banging I was about to
bang the table here but I will not do
that but the table would also have uh
you know Quakes so they don't filed
quickly depending on whether you have a
gaseous planet or a crust-like planet
like Earth so Jupiter Saturn all the big
gaseous planets in our solar system they
also have uh Quakes wait a minute Connie
you're saying sanitary they play sound
anywhere is a quake to you yeah that's
true you do so a guitarist what we're
doing right now is kind of causing them
this the tiniest the tiniest Quakes
of course you're you're creating uh
sound waves oh my god listen to Woody
also asks by the way on this same topic
what what different would the ice giants
experience Quakes I guess you've said
the answer is yes and what possible
differences would there be between Earth
water ice frozen methane and nitrogen
Quakes yeah so so the the right that's a
bit wait just a quick thing so we've got
ice in Uranus Neptune uh the ice giants
and we've got sort of gases in Jupiter
Saturn we've got Earth's crust here and
so uh presumably
uh you've uh Connie you've got some
portfolio of who makes what kind of
sound under what conditions so that you
can decode what you hear is that correct
that's correct and so the the the
frequency of the sound waves of all
these Heavenly Bodies is really
determined by the density of the object
right and so stars are gases and their
density is very different from the
density here on Earth they're very low
yeah or in Jupiter yeah so uh by
measuring the frequencies
of the Quakes we know
quite directly how big the object is and
what its density is and if you know
these two then you know the mass so you
said basic tools right you said you said
that on the sun you you measure the
Quakes because some parts of the Sun get
brighter relative to others because
they're hotter how do you do that with
just a planet sitting out there in space
yeah we need to send some space mission
oh there to come closer and to be able
to see this and so for stars we also I
mean this this is a Boeing research
field in astrophysics why because we
recently had the luck of uh being able
to measure the brightness variations
with satellites yeah we don't have a
seismograph that we can put there
literally like for the Earth but we sent
instruments that that measure these tiny
variations in the gas you know okay so
it I'm a I'm a I'm an old old world
astrophysicist So when you say we we
make these measurements by going there
that's cheating that's cheating yeah
yeah you don't go there that's tabletop
science at that level yeah if you get to
go there yeah but you're saying it's the
same kind of features in a gaseous
Planet some parts will be a little
warmer or cooler than others on the
surface and that'll tell you that
that'll give you seismic information
about what's going on inside yeah as
soon as the density changes for whatever
reason density changes give pressure
waves and these are sound waves right
okay
and so
um the follow-up part from uh from James
what's the largest recorded Quake not
found on Earth
oh well we have the the slowest quake in
a star like it can take several several
months in in in Period well for the sun
it's five minutes huh by the way for
those who don't know yet the solar
Quakes go up and down create sounds wave
with periods of about a few minutes five
minutes at their strongest so for a very
big blue supergiant star it takes months
before the Quake went up and down
so just to be clear the normal
frequencies we listen to are hundreds
and thousands of cycles per second and
that's that's what our our eardrum and
brain will record and you're saying
these are Cycles every five minutes
yes and that's or even every month or
even every month so that's why you have
to shift it back to our audio range yeah
otherwise we don't we would never even
know what was happening that's right
these are slow waves to human standards
right you'd vaporize first but yeah
right while you're vaporized you would
not know you were in the middle of a
star Quake I say that's right that's
wild for me so incredibly slow but
presumably hugely energetic
uh yes that's
that's true yeah so the the energy of
each wave can be quite tremendous but
that also depends on the type of waves
that you're dealing with yeah
yeah okay wow all right well let's take
a quick break and we're to come back to
more star quakes
so it was like what
yeah
but to Connie everything's a quake so
we'll get more into that in this episode
of Star Talk Cosmic queries when we
return
we're back Star Talk Cosmic queries
we're talking about star Quakes and my
co-host Matt kirschen Matt uh where can
I find you on the internet well you can
find my podcast probably science I I
start with the Neil episode that's
always a nice place yeah I was a guest
once on your probably science I just
thought by now it would have been called
certainly science I just I thought it
was evolutionary but you know what the
longer we do the show the more probably
it gets
it's going to descend through possibly
to ah
and uh technically on Instagram but I'm
very rarely there okay Christian
k-a-r-s-h-e-n and we have as our
in-house expert right now on starquakes
uh an astro size professor of Astro
seismology in the Netherlands but right
now uh Connie Arts I think I pronounced
that right is visiting New York City at
a place called the flat iron Institute
which is in the Flatiron section of
Manhattan and very cool science is
happening there all manner of science it
started with sort of math and
astrophysics but it's it's spilling into
biology and and computer science where
very deep problems that need high
performance Computing and clever people
to solve them are invited to then uh
gather their talents and try to solve
the secret of the Universe
and Connie Arts is on sabbatical this
year so Connie we're delighted to have
you as part of this podcast
very grateful to be here thank you yeah
yeah so we've got some more questions
but before we do that I just want to be
clear that most people's understanding
of the word quake
is
I think built in is that it's abrupt and
short-lived that's kind of built into
our life experience with a quake and
but we now hearing about Quakes on
completely different time scales should
you have invented another word to
describe a quake that
moves on the scale of days or months
rather than seconds or minutes sure and
I use the term Stark weights for popular
lectures but actually in in our
professional life we we speak of Stellar
oscillations so the global oscillations
they're smooth they're properly behaved
so for stars it's a bit less abrupt than
for uh
earthquakes let's say Okay okay so if on
Earth they were Earth oscillations then
Matt you maybe you wouldn't have to hide
under a desk or in the structural beams
of the house I would just write it out I
just ride it I'd surf it out keep the
knees to flexed keep keep your cool
stable that's all you need but you would
get seasick all the time you know
because you would always be there you
know yeah eyes on the horizon that's the
secret always look out the window don't
you have another subjects inside are you
tend to be surfing one day out in Los
Angeles and teach me so Matt what do we
have else do we have for Connie we've
got some great questions by the way I
just side note I I love when we have
topics like this when it's something
that is close to Neil's wheelhouse but
just outside it when it's when it's like
in your field of astrophysics but
something that you've never really
encountered they're my favorite episodes
because because you like look at how
much of an idiot I am that's what you're
saying I love it when you yeah we just
just at the edge of Neil's knowledge
it's my favorite
it's it's the best uh well that was my
favorite episodes where I learned stuff
so absolutely absolutely
so um I'm gonna combine these two
questions I like to do this because uh
because I want to hear their names
anyway yeah absolutely Dylan and uh from
NAU in Flagstaff and Alejandro Reynoso
from Monterey have both asked about what
we can actually learn from the
oscillation of stars Dylan says can we
predict its age and or understand the
core and also to All Stars oscillate or
just dying Stars supermassive Stars main
sequence stars and then Alejandro says
what have you learned from analyzing
star Quakes that you couldn't learn with
other methods so basically they're both
asking what specifically is it that we
can learn from these Quakes and I'm
going to tighten that question and say
what are you learning that we didn't
otherwise
figure out through other means okay if
there's one words that I have to ask to
that question it is rotation of stars
that's more than one word but internal
rotation of stars you know and why is
that let me give the analogy with music
again so we have sound waves that are
happening inside a star but the gas in
this tire is rotating around right and
what do you get when you put a a
musician in a theater play and you make
the podium rotate just for the fun of it
as a surprise to the musician they get
pissed off musicians that's what you get
exactly I like that experiment actually
do that but the symphony is destroyed
that's what the audience would say now
for me as an astro seismologist
the frequencies of the Waves get shifted
right a Doppler shift yeah they get
shifted because of the extra motion due
to the rotation and we can measure that
and we're not measuring that at the
surface of the star but in the inside
the star where this the Stark weight has
its strongest energy
right
and so what we have come to realize is
that the theory of how Stars evolve
relying on how they rotate in their
interior is quite off it's it's not very
good and that's not surprising right
because we could only measure before we
had star plates we could only measure
the rotation of the star at its external
layer like for the sun you see that you
see the tiny little dark spots of the
sun rotating around if you're patient
every 26 days you see them back in your
line of sight but so the sun rotates
with a period of about 26 days but
that's just the outer layers it doesn't
say at all how it rotates in its
interior so if you have no information
what can you do well you think well it
won't be that different you just assume
it's the same right yeah everything else
rotates as an as a kind of a unified
object why would I even think some lower
level would rotate at a different rate
well the stars have many more surprises
to that us
astrophysicists have imagination
what a smack oh did you eat man man did
I just hear this woman correctly here
yeah I stand by it I'm on team star on
this one
that's a Smackdown right there yes I
always say the stars are right the
theory is wrong if they if it doesn't
match with each other right so thanks to
the frequency shifts of these waves we
can now measure how Stars rotate around
and why is that important well if they
rotate faster or slower then their
material gets mixed in a different way
yeah that's also something you can
imagine if you take the analogy with
coffee drinkers you know if you if you
like coffee with milk you pour milk into
your coffee and you don't wait until you
know until everything is mixed because
then the coffee is cold and it doesn't
taste well anymore no you take a spoon
and you rotate your coffee in my turn
terminology that is saying you bring
angular momentum to the coffee cup and
what why do you do that's what everyone
says when they're having coffee that's
what everybody does without saying it
and that's because everybody prefers
well mixed coffee with milk and so I'm
assuming that the flat iron Institute
that is the just the coffee station
there has angular momentum implements
yes
how much angle momentum would you like
on your coffee this morning
do you want do you want some metal
angular momentum implements or one of
the wooden straight ones it's uh well we
could do an experiment of how people do
that huh but you know the diversity of
human beings taking their spoons will be
large and in Stars there's a whole range
of internal rotation frequencies that we
have measured in we have about 2 000
stars now for which this has been
measured by many groups in the world
with Astro seismologists and so the life
of the stars is really going slower
if I look at
the measurements you mean our estimates
for their life expectancy need to be
updated to have them live longer than we
originally thought is that what you're
saying yeah particularly for the big
massive stars is that because they're
mixing more material into their core
yeah giving them a little more lease on
life yeah and they they get more uh
material into their inner part and in
the inner part of the stars is actually
a nuclear reactor for me not because the
the their the simplest uh constituent
which is hydrogen is turned into helium
by nuclear fusion as stars are
masterpieces in that but if you bring
more hydrogen into that area where it's
hot and dense enough then the star can
live longer and so the rotation affects
how much nuclear fuel you bring inside
it's it's interior actually that was
about to be the opposite of what I would
have guessed because I was wondering
whether the sort of the stirring effect
would have
sped up the fusion reaction by kind of
you know you can increase the speed of a
chemical reaction I know that's
different from a nuclear reaction by by
stirring the chemicals together or by
increasing the energy in there but
you're saying it's the opposite because
it's bringing more fuel in from the
outside yeah so once the nuclear burning
is ongoing the nuclear fusion installs
is stable uh the stars are are can do
that very well we humans can't do that
here now everything I know about the
nuclear furnace says that it's pretty
small relative to the size of the star
itself do your waves give you enough
information about tiny areas like a like
the nuclear core yeah well tiny it's ten
percent of the mass that they typically
takes part in the nuclear fusion so it's
still 10 so it's not of the mass even if
it's physically small it's got It's got
a lot of mass going on yeah because the
density is very high and so if you if
you change that 10 to say 12 percent
that sounds like you know it's only two
percent you know but that's a lot of
fuel yes you bring into your nuclear
reactor and
yeah yeah it can really change the
lifetime of the Stars so that's that's
uh so and Matt if you were in the center
of a star you'd be dense too I just
wanted oh thanks
it's one of the nicest things anyone's
ever said to me
we've got more questions Matt bring them
up we do Aziz from Saudi Arabia says uh
I I wonder if it's possible for a Star
to have a star Quake so strong caused by
for example nuclear fission or Fusion
happening or abnormally fast or caused
by any other reason to lose Mass I
thought I'd ask that one because we're
already talking about Fusion you know in
the formation of stars in the galaxy you
can get shock waves across a gas cloud
that's otherwise mining its own business
and it can trigger gravitational
collapse and other interesting features
so I'd love that question Connie so our
star quiz just the product of what's
going on or are there participant in
causing what's going on yes so you can
have all sorts of course reasons why
stars have these oscillations right
and they can indeed be caused by the by
the
the fierce turbulence in the in the core
of a very massive star because it's you
know it's we call that convection so
turbulent motions and they create waves
also because again they they make the
gas you know compress and expect but
there are also other reasons why Stars
can have star grades think of them the
Earth Moon system and Tides well half of
the stars are even more if you go to
higher masses they live together with
two
and then they have time binary star
systems just like in that scene in Star
Wars where Luke comes out is that the
the sand planet and he sees a double
sunset uh that's the only accurate
science in the entire history
yeah
okay so what happens there so you got
you have a you have a gravitational
title dance and they that's right they
they rotate around each other and they
pull they give a tidal pool right and so
you could also say that you know for me
tidal forces are are actually forced
oscillation you know I I say everybody
oscillates in nature so
um when the stars are close enough
together the tidal oscillations as I
call them
uh are very strong can be very strong so
that's another reason why Stars can have
uh so these are like a tidal bulge in
the direction of the of the object
responsible for it yeah see in my older
years I I have a title bulge as well
I'm watching for that just to see what I
can do about it yeah yeah you want to
prevent it but do you like it let's get
it
yeah
all right Matt give me some more Quentin
from Switzerland says and I don't know
what I don't know what uh Quentin's
referring to so hopefully one of you two
can fill me in says do you need more
data to exactly figure out what happened
with beta juice recently Beetlejuice
fatal juice it seems yes it does
pronounce Beetlejuice like the film but
spell differently it seems pretty
unlikely that we will witness a similar
event in the near future so what is it
what did happen I gotta lead off with
this and then we'll get the actual
answer from Connie okay I heard but
Betelgeuse is one of the brightest stars
in the night sky it's a important star
in one of the most dominant
constellations of all 88 dominant
insides and and appearance is Orion
Orion is visible in both the northern
and southern hemispheres because it
straddles the equator on the sky and so
there's this start Betelgeuse one of the
biggest baddest red giants in the known
universe and someone told me do You
Realize Beetlejuice is getting dimmer I
said no what what and I looked up and I
went
it was
because my whole life Betelgeuse was a
certain brightness relative to other
stars in the constellation I cannot
communicate to you my loss of breath in
the moment I looked up and I say what is
happening is this you know is this
is the seventh seal broken is there some
is this something biblical
you know what's going on yeah I I I
nearly freaked out so what happened to
Betelgeuse a year ago when it just got
mysteriously dim like it was it went to
less than half its normal brightness and
that had never been observed ever in any
time anybody's been looking at the star
so we're going to blame you for this
Connie what what happened
well Beetlejuice is behaving normally at
the start it's you know it's a super
giant right it's a very big star and so
these stars are nearing the end of their
life and so they're they're puffing up
their material and they're blowing it
away so to speak right and so when
material gets lost from the Star well
then for us the star is obscured because
it's in between the super giant and
Earth there's material that is being
expelled
now for me as an astro seismologist
that's a bit annoying that behavior
because Beetlejuice has star Quakes but
all that material that's being expelled
makes it hard to still measure them it's
blocking your view it's blocking the
view and that's also the reason why for
us it's difficult to do Astro seismology
from ground-based telescopes you know
the stars are up there they people say
they twinkle right
but that twinkling that you see with
your eyes that's not the star that's
actually the Starlight that is being
portrayed by the earth atmosphere right
and so it's a bit similar but then then
the twinkling of Beetlejuice is caused
by the material it has expelled but it
does have also oscillations and these
oscillations can tell us how old it is
and how big it is
ETC all right it's made of just ready to
blow because we think that's a supernova
category star is it yeah people I I said
oh my gosh something bad is going to
happen it's gonna happen it's gonna have
is that bad no it's not bad because it
will explode eventually but that can
take still so while so you know you
don't want to go and look every day
because you may need to have some
patience like we're trained to think
that if something blows up it's bad okay
I'm sorry yeah yeah these guys are like
it's exciting this is more data this is
yeah it's more data okay all right this
is like the rocket launchers who the
rocket blows up on the launch pad you
say oh are you upset by that failure no
that was an experiment rich in data yeah
so yeah well but I'm saying it's good
because it enriches the Galaxy with
Metals with carbon with oxygen with iron
and you know
eat that as human beings so okay just
just to be clear Matt yeah
astrophysicists are uh we are very lazy
with regard to the periodic table of
elements and so any element that's not
hydrogen or helium we call it a metal
but this freaks out chemists okay it is
we're self-aware of this bad vernacular
but the point is 98 of the universe is
hydrogen and helium and so and the rest
is just other stuff so we just we just
experimental error so we just call them
metals and I'm just covering Connie's
ass right here yeah when she said the
metals such as carbon right no she's
being fully astrophysical in in uh in in
the referencing so but but Connie you
speak of this
um this this blockage of ejected gas
like of course it would do that yet it
hasn't done it in the thousands of years
we've been observing the night sky and
mapping its brightness relative to other
stars so do you have an account for why
it's doing it now and it's not doing it
regularly oh but you see we
astrophysicists have to be very patient
because the time skills when for stars
to do this kind of stuff you know that's
like hundreds of thousands of years you
know and okay so you're saying if we see
it only once in a few thousand years
that could be a regular interval yeah
yeah yes okay all right she got out of
that one Matt I think it's just annoying
that's we human beings only live for
like 100 years at most yeah if we are
lucky yeah
in an astronomical time scale that's
that instantaneously very short yeah all
right we gotta take our last break and
when we come back more Astro seismology
with a professor of Astro seismology
Connie arts on Star Talk Cosmic queries
we're back for the third and final
segment of Star Talk Cosmic queries the
Astro seismology Edition
with our expert a professor of Astro
seismology Connie arts and she's on
sabbatical now at the Flatiron Institute
in New York City which has gathered all
manner of of computational scientists in
multiple Fields where they not only
compare notes with each other in their
own field but across disciplines perhaps
there's some cross-pollination that can
lead to discoveries that wouldn't
otherwise happen and Connie you are
based in uh in the Netherlands and in
Belgium you have two different
appointments that of course the strong
overlap in what they are but this is
very cool that we have you here we're
borrowing you from Europe and great to
have you here in my hometown New York
city so Matt uh we have a few minutes
for a few more questions let's see how
many more we can slip in
these questions are from our patreon
members still correct they they are yeah
uh so Kevin the sommelier asks uh does
asteroid seismology coincide with the
data we can get from the James Webb's
Space Telescope are we able to see those
Quakes in infrared
yeah and also then gives a wine
recommendation oh yeah because I told
them I would not allow him to ask
another question if he's going to Bill
himself as a summer year there's got to
be a recommendation so he recommends
specifically for our for our Belgian
guest says with milfreet uh Kevin
recommends a bottle of Muska day surely
LaGrange so there we go thank you Kevin
for that okay that sounds like a dessert
wine all right let the world know
recommendation I love that question
Connie I didn't even think to think
about this because I'm PRI I love
Stellar Evolution but I'm primarily a
Galaxy's guy in a large-scale structure
guy which which the James Webb Telescope
is exquisitely tuned to observe the
early universe and it would never occur
to me to imagine if it could be of use
to you uh in thinking about star Quakes
so what how does how is your field uh
put your sort of hooks into the data of
that telescope well the James Webb is is
fantastic but I would not uh spend its
time on Star Quakes and so let me
explain why you know James Webb can
Pierce very deep into the early Universe
in the infrared but what I need as a
seismologist is really long-term
measurements and that's why we love the
Kepler mission of NASA and now the test
mission and the future Plato Mission
because they're staring at stars for
years without interruption and so you
don't want to spend James Webb on that
because it has as you say so much other
fantastic extra Galactic signs to do so
interesting I don't want to look on
James Webb right of course at all times
in in our field man we're always
judging whether you need one particular
telescope up for that task versus
another telescope that might be either
more available or less
a Cutting Edge because you want The
Cutting Edge telescope for The Cutting
Edge science that's going to break open
whole new Fields typically so yeah
that's a very important point that
you're mentioning there Connie and but I
I want to also ask that's part of the
Great computational challenge because if
you have a lot of quakes of all
different frequencies
short measurements cannot distinguish
one from the other correct you need a
very long Baseline so that you can tease
out of the data
frequencies that are represented enough
to know that they're real did I
characterize that yeah that's that's
that's very well described and in
practice you know the the Precision of
the frequency goes as one over the total
uh time base of the measurements yeah so
if Kepler measures four years well
that's one over four years in in in
frequency resolution as we call it
capacity to unravel these these star
Quake frequencies so we we need we need
to be very Astro seismologists are very
patient people
so what you're saying is if you uh so
I'd like that so if you measure
something for four years you can't
really say much about frequencies that
occur on two-year time scales because
you would have only had one or two
cycles in there and that's not enough to
even know if they're real yes so you
need enough Cycles in your Baseline of
data to be able to say yeah that's real
yes it's repeating and it's reliable
yeah that's right and so that's why we
need these long time series and we can
only do the work once we achieve that so
we need dedicated space missions to
achieve that and James Webb is just not
one of them I got it interesting please
so leave James Webb to the people who
need it and I miss one of them all right
it's very magnanimous of you yes yeah so
so just to update people so Kepler was a
telescope that looked in one part of the
sky looking for
um for earth-like planets around
sun-like Stars studying them for a long
period of time tests that what's that
that's an acronym for what I forgot
transiting
exoplanets exoplanets survey satellites
satellite thank you yeah Tess will see
the entire sky but not quite to the
depth and space that Kepler did and so
now what is Plato going to do and is
that also an acronym yeah well Plato
stands for uh planetary transits and
oscillations of stars and Plato is
actually gonna from from from
construction combines The Best of Both
Worlds of the Kepler Mission and the
task mission in the sense that we need
long-term observations but we also need
the whole not the whole sky but a very
very big part of it to have copies of
the Earth in our line of sights that
rotate around copies of the sun it takes
a year for us to revolve and so Plato
has that building it's actually it's uh
24 telescopes on one big platform oh my
gosh okay I didn't know that about it
okay so so it's uh it's a
multi-telescope instrument that is being
built by the European Space Agency right
now I tend to call it my third child
because I've been in oh you're you're
deep with involved in the design yeah
yeah yeah objectives of it
congratulations for that yeah yeah so
that's exciting I want to see the data
before I retire yeah Kepler was a famous
German mathematician who coincided with
Galileo actually
in time and we all heard of Plato but I
I don't know any tests so Tess is an
acronym but not an acronym of a famous
scientist of the past exactly exactly
yeah so they don't always work out the
way well yeah just as long as the
Machinery works for us that's the truth
you don't care what the hell
[Laughter]
all right so Matt keep it going what do
you have I I am gonna to try and get
through as many of these questions as
possible I'm gonna try and look at
myself see if she can do a lightning
round here we go we're combining four
questions they said it couldn't be done
but four different questioners uh
between because a lot of people have
asked about the effect of uh sunspots on
Star Quakes and how they affect Earth so
Charles macko asks how they affect star
Quakes
um Trevor Mills says how close would a
nearby star have to be for a star Quake
to be considered dangerous for Earth and
then Sarah Rosen says how big of a CME
would it take for the Sun's gravity to
be negatively affected and Gina Martin
says why didn't the one the star Quake
back in 2004 wipe us out I've read that
it released more energy than our own
some would admit in 150 000 years
okay so let me tighten all those up so
so Connie uh clearly there are Quakes
going on all the time and I presume that
a CME a coronal mass ejection is itself
detectable as some kind of Quake
activity
so and of course sunspots are measures
of the activity of the Sun so but you
haven't mentioned uh solar flares or or
coronal mass ejections or sunspots yet
not much in this conversation so what
role do they play in all of this oh well
the role they played is they they
disturb
the periodic oscillations of the Sun but
it's not bad for us why not because a
Corona mass ejection or or
spots that rotate around you know they
they do not give the same signal in in
the periodicity of the Quakes I'm
quaking my microphone right now
um so um you know a coronal mass
ejection is an Abrupt event it's more
like a earthquake you could say it
happens and it disappears right but it
doesn't disturb us finding uh the five
minute oscillations of the sun which are
always there yeah they get Disturbed
abruptly but then they continue and they
continue and they continue all the time
so for us you know we can we can unravel
the signal of star spots of mass
ejections even for stars other than the
sun from the always smooth periodic
oscillations so so how about the dangers
that they might pose if you do have a
coronal mass ejection that happens to
head towards us yeah so the Earth is
protected by a magnetic field that
protects us from all these high
energetic particles falling in uh on our
planet and other stars are too far away
so I mean it's only a matter of of the
solar quakes
um they are not dangerous for us that
the coronal mass ejections they disturb
our Electronics every once in a while
right but uh you know that's not a
periodic oscillation that I would call
uh solar Quakes yeah I forgot that you
enjoy events like that even if they mess
with our computers okay that's how we
that's how that's yeah I forgot that I
learned that earlier in this podcast
yeah yeah so that almost counts as a
lightning rod around Matt because she
answered three questions in one reply so
she did let's see if we get a few more
in before we call it yeah James Allen
from Brisbane in Australia says uh could
a star Quake large enough theoretically
cause a star to tear apart and with the
send a high radiation plus like a
supernova what would we what could we
learn such things from our own star
um a star quick would not rip apart a
star because it's really a smooth nice
uh periodic variability you know the the
biggest Stark weights in terms of
expansion and contraction let's say I
can make the star become bigger and
smaller by about 10 in its radius let's
say huh but not make it explode that's
another phenomenon okay again that's
people thinking that a quake is a
spontaneous bad thing
um fantastic smoothing it's fantastic
smooth
well on that same note uh Connor home
from squim Washington says is it
possible to predict where and when a
star quite will occur and if so what's
the largest predictive star quake and
how much bigger is it compared to the
largest recorded one well Stark wakes
happen all the time I keep repeating
that test so let me let me ask you
differently then what variety of your
oscillations carries the most energy
um well the the simplest Stark wakes are
radial oscillations you know up and down
and up and down so everything is
expanding and Contracting while keeping
spherical symmetry so that's about the
the you know the largest energetic uh it
can get and that's for me just a simple
oscillation because and that's what
gives us variable Stars I guess right
yeah yeah yeah so cephis are a library
yeah it's half a star I mean some huge
fraction of stars in the night sky are
variable presumably for this reason and
I heard when I was in graduate school
Connie that if you looked at every Star
close enough
with with sharp enough data they're all
variable of course they are everything
oscillates of course so we just have to
draw some arbitrary line of what we
category what we catalog as a variable
star relative to other stars but really
to you everybody's got action well we're
measuring the action up to parts per
million yeah there it is right you got
it parts per million you guys that's all
right Matt let's get one more slip one
more in before we got a call all right
uh Margaret Defoe from Milwaukee says
why didn't our solar system go binary
and what is the smallest and largest a
stock can get so we're on more general
questions about stars yeah let's let's
do it hold aside the largest and
smallest that's a whole other
astrophysics question but Connie what do
you say about why this sun is alone when
so many stars in the night sky are
binary in multiple systems yeah well if
you look at the the star with the mass
of the Sun then half of them are in in
binary so that means that half of them
are alone
right yeah so that's not so exceptional
but if you if you go to start that's not
the answer we were looking for we wanted
you to say we might have had a double
and then it blew up we want a more
sci-fi answer here we lost it was
originally a twin we lost one of them it
ate the other one in the womb
Etsy ate the other one I don't think so
I don't think so but that happens
frequently when you go to higher masses
huh if your star is born with 10 to 100
times more mass then the sun was born
with well then about 80 percent of the
stars are multiple double Stars yeah so
for the sun I think it's just a logical
consequence of there only being half of
them that live their life together okay
all right luckily for us huh it wouldn't
have been so nice here if it would have
had been living next to a star that has
exploded already yeah it has issues but
that's definitely and a yet to be
written sci-fi drama I think a Sci-Fi
Action film yeah whatever happened to
the sun's twin you got it well Connie
it's been Delight to have you uh on Star
Talk and like I said uh my city my town
is your town so I'm a native of New York
City you're visiting for the sabbatical
uh maybe we can get you up to the museum
and give you a tour and possibly extract
extort a seminar from you for our
astrophysics group yeah I love this city
so I'm very grateful that you're hosting
me excellent excellent Matt always good
to have you man oh it's a pleasure to be
here thanks for having me and this has
been great I've loved hearing about this
stuff so thanks for joining us on this
episode of StarTalk Cosmic queries star
Quakes I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson as always
bidding
keep looking up
[Music]